obviously now today i feel much more
comfortable in my job and
versus my first cfo job when i got like
when i was 32.
[Music]
jacob shulman thank you for being on 20
milliliters hi michael
very nice being here i am so excited to
learn about what it means to be
the cfo of multiple companies very very
well known companies melanox
a jfrog most recently an incredible an
incredible company
here in in silicon valley and i'm
especially curious to hear
and you know to to learn as a young
entrepreneur what are the
responsibilities and the different
mindsets that one needs to come with
when working
uh as the chief financial officer
because you know i have
i don't know finances i don't know what
that even entails you ran
over you raised over 750 million dollars
in capital you've
managed or and you've seen over 1.5
billion dollars in acquisitions
i mean these are just astonishing
numbers jacob let's just start who are
you
um i don't know it looks like i'm a
simple guy that
uh trying to achieve my you know my my
dream career and
uh and enjoy all the way through it
so so what is that what is that dream
career that you're talking about
you know i always wanted to be involved
in business
and uh you know work along
very bright entrepreneurs kind of
helping them to achieve their goals
my background is in finance and i enjoy
that side of the business
as you know entrepreneurs many times
they technologies the very bright guys
but they less let's say
knowledgeable in in finance and
scalability how to run
the businesses and back offices of
corporations
and that's right now when i when i think
about entrepreneurs i think of these
like you know crazy people who run up
and down the hallway
screaming about the strategy and and you
know how what we should be doing but
they're not necessarily
connected to the financial spreadsheets
that you know it takes to
then run a successful business that can
raise capital through the rounds
it's not just financial spreadsheets
it's it's entire back office right
how to build the scalable processes how
to
consider different decisions whether it
makes sense to raise
capital now or maybe wait until the
product is ready and
raised later into high evaluation all
this all this decision that
i'm helping them to take so yeah because
you know i think that one of the
one of the interesting phenomena that
i'm observing is that this
the millions of dollars that people are
talking about in venture funding
it's it's almost become like just you
know meaningless numbers like yeah i
raised six million oh maybe i could
raise 10 million
and or or you know and you're talking
about the different finances of a
company
and it almost seems to lose the meaning
of what is that money actually being
used for so it sounds like
you know your is your position really
understanding the core
of the of the of the company and
understanding how much money we actually
need and how are we actually going to
use it
yes absolutely so first of all what
what's our needs
right right what the runway we want to
get
but also what our core business and what
value we could get for that business
right yes many times its valuation is
very subjective
but at the end there is some substantial
business behind that
right so how do you combine this to your
needs
your valuation and what's true business
behind that this is something that
that i have made no matter so you know
it gave me the day-to-day of a cfo i i
i'm observing i talk to a lot of
founders and entrepreneurs and i see how
they operate but i've never really
you know shadowed a cfo of a of a huge
company like melanox or jfrog so
you know share with me you come to the
office in the morning what what do you
care about what's
what keeps you up at night first of all
you know when i wake up
first thing is you know to check how the
futures of the market looking
right to see what was gonna happen today
in the market
and uh especially if you thief of a
public company many times
the company shares move irrespective of
the company business
uh different drivers behind the share
price
but at the end every employee of public
company when they come
to work they open yao finance and they
see okay oh what's going on with the
company the company shares down five
percent about five percent right
is that a big thing you know when when
you're an exec in a public company
that you go and you are constantly
checking you know yahoo finance to see
what the stock price is
not constantly checking but you do want
to to have
an idea what's going on today in the
market because many times
investors might call if it's if it's
it's if it's a significant movement in
the stock
right so if that's not what's a
significant movement for example
i'd say more than five percent people
would want to
understand why why what's the reasons
for that right
and especially if you have very good
relationship with investors
they might call you and ask what's going
on with the company
right what what is it that triggering
what what are the trigger in this
movement
in the stock so you so you you can come
to the office and you see like there's a
five percent increase or decrease in
and you just get a phone call and say
hey we just i saw we just lost
a few billion dollars here can you
explain like is there anything wrong
yeah so many times you know different
investors they look at
the the title rising time horizon is
different some guys
they don't really they don't care about
daily movements because they
are with the for the long term and some
guys they
they have much much shorter right
view so this is this is obviously the
way how you choose investors in your
business
who you contacted what india starts your
target that's very important as well
so jacob what is your biggest
contribution to the company
so you know as the cfo what is like in
the top three things that you provide
that without you the company would not
be able to to continue as it's doing
today
so first of all i think my primary role
is to help the ceo of the company
to understand where we stand with our
financials what what
what's the true performance of our
business and what investments additional
investments we can allow ourselves
to make to grow the business and what
are those areas
where we could invest to help to get the
best roi
that's i think that that's the primary
role because as you know ceos they very
busy
people they they drive the product they
drive marketing they
they try to close deals and many times
they
don't have time and capacity to to to
have that
view so that's what my primary goal
second
i obviously help a lot with running in
the back office of the company
the company when you run the company
there are a lot of laws that you have to
comply with
there is you know different
etc this is something that i help with
as well because i want
the business side the ceo to focus on
the business
right those are those main areas and
obviously being
being a kind of uh um
contacting major stakeholders such as
right
investors and all that stuff so that's
the governance side of the company and
this is something also that i'm helping
with
how connected are you to the mission of
the company so
you know how connected are you to the
mission of melanox so the mission of
jfrog
rather than the financial projections of
where
the company could get to and i'm talking
when i say nation i'm talking about you
know
google's mission is to connect to the
world's information like
those types of missions are you there
with executives of course
this is you know as executive in the
company you have to believe in the
mission of the company
right you have to otherwise there's no
place for you in the company if you
don't believe in the mission you're a
leader in the company
right not just your accountant that sits
and and calculates
income and expenses no not at all right
you're a leader in the company you drive
the company
forward and if you don't believe in the
mission or of far away
from understanding the mission then
there's no way for you you have to be
in the company totally total okay so you
know talk talk a little bit about why
you enjoy being the cfo
i'm not i'm you know i am a numbers guy
i'm not but i'm not a huge economics guy
i i'm much more i think in the realm of
of you know
the engineering side of things why why
cfo why
why leading the financials of big
companies
first of all i think my background uh
fits me very well for this position but
this is something that
i always was attracted to the
the financial side right the investment
side the roi
i'm less maybe creative
on the engineering side although i do
have some engineering background
but with the time i i
i developed this capabilities of truly
understanding the financial picture of
the company
for me just to take a look at the
financials i know what's going on right
away
right so this is something that i enjoy
and this is something that
i i feel comfortable with uh to you know
to to leave that side of the business
are those similar um lessons and
understandings as
what investors need in order to invest
you know series b
onwards as you're able to actually look
at the at the details of the numbers
you know obviously investors in the
public companies and
and we see investors they're completely
different
uh considerations that they that they
make
when the public company investors
reviews the financials they typically
could value the company on certain
history of the company performance
right financial performance of course
these investors they
many times they don't even have any
history of the company
right right investors these investors
that many times just
invest into the idea and into the
entrepreneur
versus the public investors where they
typically invest into the business
already established business
comparing how they perform comparing
their success
in the market and then projecting what
would be their future success
no that makes a lot of sense and you
know i i still want to know that
you know you're seeing the companies
grow what is you know
probably the the most fun thing you take
away from
from seeing these companies grow is it
more of the early stages the later
stages because you're you're
most of your experiences in the later
stages right
now i joined melanox when there were
just 50 million dollars in revenues
wow and and i saw this uh growth when i
left mail amongst them
over billion dollar in revenues wow
three thousand
employees so obviously i saw that that
growth
and it's obviously different stages uh
you have to deal with different
different issues right when it's smaller
company
less established company you really try
to penetrate into the market
to build those processes that allow to
scale
fast if you're successful when you large
company
you you deal with a lot with kind of
management of the company uh
coordination
maybe acquiring other companies and
integrating them into the business so
it's
it's different stages you different you
have different
uh so so and as you're as you're going
through these different companies and
different
incredible experiences what are some of
the patterns that you're seeing in terms
of
are you know healthy healthy ways of
running finances there may be
maybe unhealthy ways of doing that i
mean things that i could take with me
as an entrepreneur moving forward when i
when i run my own business what are the
most critical things i should keep in
mind
besides you know bringing on a very very
good cfo
yeah critical things is first of all
it's all about
people right the people you work with
the integrity of your ceo
i would never want to work with someone
who does something
deals or anything like that right well
integrity is a big part of it
it's it's honestly honesty and integrity
that's that's very important because
you know we all come to work to enjoy
and i don't want
to have sleepless night just thinking
what might happen
right if my my partners decide hey maybe
we'll do
cut that corner or that corner no no no
so this is all about people
first and uh and and second obviously
the uh truly i
i i enjoy working with true
professionals right
that passionate about their business
totally do
as a ceo or as an entrepreneur does
the cfo well the same person usually fit
the role as the company grows because i
imagine that ra you know
you probably would get a cfo i guess
when you're i don't know series b
maybe right in the company and then
you're growing and you know eventually
you're gonna go public hopefully
and you're gonna have you know perhaps a
billion dollars in revenue
that's a very different you know a
transactional amount
from you know raising 30 million dollars
to getting now
30 to getting 100 million dollars a year
is it is it usually the same person who
can handle both or do you usually see
people shifting and changing cfos
it depends it depends on on the person
many people just enjoy working with
smaller companies and when the company
reaches a certain level then they
uh just decide to leave and go back to
smaller companies
same true for for the b for other guys
who enjoy working from b companies
there there are some people like me
enjoy to see all the way through
growth right and many times you just you
know
grow with the company and you use a lot
of common sense
totally totally talk to me a little bit
about about this idea of seeing
seeing big growth um as a strategy
versus getting bottled up in the current
in the current finances so
you're looking at you know financial
statements in the back office and what's
happening but you also have to imagine
what's possible for the company to
achieve one day so how do you balance
the two and what are the
what are the ways that you are able to
then think about the big picture
yeah so obviously you have to analyze
the size of your market
your potential your competition what
they could take
so a lot of what if scenarios that you
build in a lot of
different uh kind of uh
projections that you're trying to build
and see hey what what makes sense how
how big could it be and what makes sense
to invest today to get there right
versus you know maybe just the milk in
the existing market so
it's but that's something that's
changing all the time right i mean
it looks like your market the
competition on a
strategic level yeah you have to do that
every so often right
typically on the strategic side things
don't change
every every day right but you definitely
have to go through this exercise every
so often
to see because different markets change
at different pace
right if you're in a very very fast
change of market then you have to do
it much faster versus maybe
i don't know established markets with
not many players then maybe
uh you don't have to do that that often
yeah is it a very scary
job what you're doing i mean you know
managing
because at the end you're sort of it
sounds to me like you're the backbone of
the company like
always the company can look at you and
say like like jacob are we good
are we good yeah we're good we're good
and and you're you're the one that's
keen on all the numbers
you know what's gonna happen in a month
you're projecting what's gonna happen in
the year
it sounds like a lot of responsibility
honestly uh i'm still learning how to
manage my own
you know my own finances properly you're
managing you know billions of dollars
is it so is it scary sometimes no no
it's not um obviously you have to be
uh properly prepared for that right
and and it all comes with experience if
uh
obviously now today i feel much more
comfortable in my job when
versus my first c4 job when i got like
when i was 32
right that was that was a bit scary no
it's not like is it what was that like
getting your first cfo at 32 and for the
first time right like
you know you have huge weight on your
shoulders and
kind of weighs on you right and and and
to make decisions knowing that
you are the last one who who makes
decision and the business will perform
based on your decision that that's
that's something that
you have to get used to
how did that end how does that turn out
at the end
that was very successful you know that
my first cfo job i
joined the company that was going
through some sort of restructuring
and uh you know
it was a bad very successful
restructuring the company turned
profitable
and and it was it was very good the good
exercise for me to to understand you
know kind of to get my hands dirty in
in different things now incredible and
you know
so you've seen you've seen growth at
mellanox from
uh from 50 million a year to or you say
a billion a year
a jfrog also huge like fast fast fast
growing company
is that really where your excitement is
in the fast growing companies oh yeah of
course you you want to come to
to the office and deal with you know
with different things
right every day and um i
i'm not the person who who kind of
waiting to do the routine stuff every
day
so the company that grow and present
those opportunities
and that's what excited me so if you
have to give some financial advice and
obviously you're
you're not supposed to give financial
advice informally but if you were to
give financial advice
strategically to young entrepreneurs
that are starting their businesses or
even you know
entrepreneurs who have now raised their
series a and are moving forward
what are the most important things that
the ceo
should keep in mind given your knowledge
of the cfo position
yeah always be frugal right google don't
don't
don't throw away money when you don't
need to because
markets are volatile our economic
environment
is very unstable so just cash is a king
i don't say don't invest but you know
where you invest what's your expectation
from that investment
and just don't don't throw over money
right
i mean when you deal with these sums of
money how granular does a company get i
mean when you're talking about
you know when you're talking about a
hundred million dollar
uh deal you know i always thought to
myself i remember
i even asked a friend when i was younger
you know you buy a house
for let's say five hundred thousand
dollars if you
what if you could just ask like if you
were to go to that dealer and say hey
can you give me a 500
discount on the house they would say yes
right nobody would nobody would cancel
the deal
yet in our day-to-day lives we think a
lot before we
spend five hundred dollars so and and in
the same realm
i'm thinking you know when you have a
hundred million dollar deal
with and you've seen those deals how
granular do people get about you know
the the millions or or is it just okay
let's just round it up to the next
nicest number
and and make everybody happy i think at
any deal it all depends on the
materiality
right okay uh deal of
500 dollars hundred dollars is his
material to that deal
right but then deal 500 million dollars
hundred dollars is nothing
right so really when you focus on
material
things and not just not just on penis
that's what helps you to think
strategically on the other hand
on the other hand uh my accounting
department when they reconcile bank
accounts they have to go to pianist
right and this is what they expect from
them
[Music]
sure okay now that means it really
depends on their role and
depends on the materiality of you i'm
sure i'm sure
jacob before we leave i have to ask you
the most important question
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
um future future because
future i always think try to think
several years ahead yeah but that's
something that
that guides me and that's why future
you know different people live in
different time right some people live in
present
yeah i'm always thinking about future
present is less
less concerning what i always kind of
think few
few steps ahead amazing that's that's
what it is
um i think uh the second would be fun
because you know we spend so much time
at work
and i i'd like to do what i like to do
and to have fun with that right and
third
um
i don't know maybe different experiences
because
other other than work you have your
life going on right so you want to enjoy
the life as well
work is very important component of of
my
life but uh i have chosen my experience
interest other than work
i love it i did not expect those three
words from this
from a a you know a really really
accomplished cfo but so
i'm i always love being surprised but
jacob thank you very much for the time
thank you for
uh for your inspiration and for teaching
me we didn't even talk about j
ventures and early stage investing but
but we'll leave that for another time
but thank you very much thank you
michael very much for having me thanks
take care bye